[Música]
conversar bater papo e contar histórias
na língua falada na língua oral é a
mesma coisa
existe uma diferença a língua de sinais
também é assim bater papo conversar em
língua de sinais e contar uma história e
língua de sinais
é muito diferente quando contamos
histórias
acrescentamos elementos visuais
diferentes de bater um papo
muitas pessoas aprendem alguns sinais e
pensão posso traduzir pega um livro e
começam a olhar as palavras em língua
portuguesa e apresentar diversos sinais
na sequência estou contando uma história
um sinal outro sinal por exemplo a
história da chapeuzinho vermelho
a menina estava caminhando muito das
árvores encontrou um louco olhou e
perguntou o que você tem na sua cola a
menina disse bolo logo disse
onde você vai na casa da vovó
vocês perceberam essa questão de um
sinal depois de um outro sinal
vejam que seria contar uma história a
menina passeava pela floresta em meio a
muitas árvores lobo à espreita observava
ele foi até ela e disse a menina
o que você tem nesta sexta
percebem que existe uma especialidade
que não é somente os sinais que dão
conta de narra que acontece que eu tenho
observado em alguns contextos por
exemplo a feira do livro em algumas
feiras
normalmente temos oficinas com ouvintes
contando histórias
muitos em muitas situações é essa a
realidade onde contadores narram
histórias para diversas crianças surdas
que ficam interessadas fascinados pela
aquela história que é contada
do outro lado a gente tem crianças
surdas que têm acessibilidade garantida
tenho intérprete traduzir nossas
histórias mas criamos uma triangulação
essa informação então ela não chega
diretamente ao público surdo sempre vai
passar pelo atravessamento de um
intérprete
e isso é um pouco diferente é necessário
pensar nos contadores surdos que contam
e narram histórias na língua de sinais e
produzem então a questão de um modelo
identitário surdo e sobre isso eu tenho
uma experiência que quando eu trabalhei
dentro de uma escola de surdos
principalmente na disciplina de língua
de sinais e incentivava os alunos a
produzirem suas histórias na língua de
sinais
o desenvolvimento lingüístico buscava
diversos livros então de temáticas
variadas por exemplo normalmente a gente
tem uma recorrência ao uso de histórias
clássicas por exemplo dos contos de
fadas a chapeuzinho vermelho
os três porquinhos e fé diversas
histórias mas somente essas histórias
não eu buscava outros livros para que os
alunos pudessem ter conhecimento
mesmo com relações temáticas como a
páscoa o natal o dia das mães essas
temáticas então que estavam na escola
na escola a gente buscava então livros
ampliar o conhecimento e aumentar o
fluxo de informação
nessas fotos que eu trago para vocês é
de uma feira do livro do ano de 2002
a temática então era contar a história
da branca de neve
todo mundo conhece a história mas pensar
na branca de neve surda para contar uma
história província também a branca de
neve surta a rainha má
surda também ea rainha conversava com o
espelho e perguntava esse espelho
espelho meu
neste reino existe alguém que sinaliza
melhor do que eu e um espelho e dizia
não não existe ninguém
a rainha disse aqui eu sou a melhor
sinalizadora desse reino um outro
momento ela perguntou existe alguém que
sinaliza melhor do que eu e eu espero
respondeu a um termo sim branca de neve
é surda também raia disse que absurdo
chamem o caçador
corte as mãos a branca de neve percebam
que a gente traz elementos culturais
adaptando e pensando na cultura surda na
comunidade surda na valorização da
língua de sinais
então o projeto que eu tenho organizado
dentro de escolas e tudo mais né e eu
tenho um filho de sete anos que eu conto
história meu filho 21 com história pra
eles
para ele em língua de sinais e eu
pensava e as crianças surdas
elas também precisam ter acesso aos
livros e à literatura e é por isso então
que foi criado o canal 11 aventureiras
com o objetivo de buscar os livros
infantis e traduzir tanto livros
nacionais com livros internacionais de
temáticas variadas onde
conta histórias em língua de sinais
eu sei porque muitas vezes as pessoas se
perguntam porque mãos aventureiras
porque as mãos
as mãos são um símbolo de valorização da
comunidade surda porque é o meio de
comunicação das pessoas surdas é pela
língua de sinais é pelas mãos que se dá
a expressão a comunicação à informação e
à aventura como o mergulho do
conhecimento o mergulho na ampliação dos
aprendizados então as mãos aventureiras
é pelos exatamente nisso então contar
histórias
mas para quem a maioria dos surdos que
estão incluído em escola de surdos às
vezes não tem a presença de um
intérprete tem dificuldade então de ter
acesso a esses materiais
então o material é disponibilizado
gratuitamente pode ser consumido por
esse sujeito que podem ampliar o seu
vocabulário da língua de sinais
uma outra questão é que 95% das crianças
surdas nascem lares ouvintes de paz
ouvintes enfrenta em algumas situações
problemas de comunicação então os vídeos
disponibilizados para essas crianças são
uma possibilidade de informar os pais
também podem assistir e aprender alguns
sinais
eu trago algumas fotos para vocês então
pra falar um pouco dessa história
muitas vezes as pessoas pensam que a
organização é um elemento central numa
narração mas quando a gente pensa na
ampliação disso para a sinalização por
exemplo andar a cavalo sem nenhuma
expressão como expressão
o movimento o vento as expressões então
saem do nível da oralidade e passam para
a expressão facial
a ampliação e uma articulação então no
ato de contar histórias
vocês conhecem essa história o sanduíche
da maricota é um livro muito famoso e
muita gente conhece é traduzir essa
história então né contando que ela
montou o sanduíche com um pouco a
campainha tocou percebam essa
movimentação do olhar
ela deixa o sanduíche e vai abrir a
porta
na outra história
o cachorro de isola tá faltando na outra
parte da chave está faltando um moço e
aí este movimento do sinal de hoje é
colocado dentro do sanduíche não é só
coloca osso mas este movimento de
deslocamento até o sanduíche nessa
história do london lobo por do lobinho
bom uma pinho pequenininho conversa com
o globo adulto e quando ele se óleo eles
se encontram os focinhos se tocam
é esse movimento que é utilizado numa
outra parte da história o lobo adulto
disco o podium lobinho tão pequenininho
ele faz este movimento de pegar o louco
né então do solo a contar histórias
também falamos pensamos no olhar olhar
sinal de olhar de me olhar vocês a
platéia estão me olhando me assistindo
são muitos olhos na minha direção não
apenas uma pessoa
muitas pessoas então o uso do sinal
olhar diferente em diferentes contextos
no na história da centopéia e seus
sapatinhos
ela foi comprar um sapato e ficou
admirada e aí a gente consegue observar
a expressão de admiração para os
sapatinhos enquanto que na história vai
ser vagem a menina selvagem que vivia na
floresta como a história
moby que muitos conhecem a menina estava
sentada e olhando de forma estranha com
estranhamento com as pessoas que
admiravam então são formas de olhar
diferentes
ainda na história da centopéia os
sapatinhos esse é o sinal do sapato mas
européia poderia colocar um único sapato
calça um único sapato
a gente tem os sapatinhos pra cada
pezinho da centopéia se ficou apertado
tiros sapatinhos européia e pega um
número maior e tenta encaixar em cada um
dos pés
existem muitas vezes o uso de um sinal
com muitos significados como este aqui
utilizado na casa assombrada
a casa é assombrada a menina selvagem
eu tenho muito medo de dormir porque
embaixo da cama tem um monstro
eu não gosto de filmes de terror
o único sinal com muitos significados
então em cada história e cada história
diferente e os surdos vão se apropriando
destas histórias e da língua de sinais e
percebendo que existe muita diferença
entre bater papo e contar e narrar uma
história se apropriam disso e entendem
que a língua de sinais deve ser
valorizada o orgulho surdo orgulho da
língua de sinais
obrigado
[Aplausos]